hello everybody hope they are good today
is Monday so this is going to be the
first Bitcoin update of the week if you
haven't read yet the Bitcoin soon the
update go and have a look because I
figured out some important things in the
chart but basically you can see that we
are in some kind of a range here okay
we've been playing around the 50 main
the four hour time frame for quite some
time I'd like to run a couple of Longs
you know after we tested us support here
but you can see the you know Bitcoin
didn't really go up so I end up closing
the streets I break even and in
yesterday's Bitcoin update you know I
posted before this scandals to close
um I was telling you guys you know we
are between the 50 May in the photo time
frame that is the current support and
the 50-minute daily time frame that's
going to be a resistance so you know if
you want to go into long then what you
need to see is Bitcoin going up testing
the daily 50ma support and then that's
when you can open along towards this
level here okay if you break this level
you can see how he's been playing out in
the zone area between resistance support
resistance all right uh if it break this
Zone then again the same plane okay
breakable retail support and
continuation
to fill this week here are 28 250
because this target here I mean it's a
week you know you know what happens the
week weeks always get filled if you go
to the polkadot chart this is a trade
that I took uh on Saturday I usually
don't treat on the weekends but look at
this week here okay this week is amazing
of course I have to trade this week you
know uh it was uh very easy trade
because I know how to trade this price
was consolidating in this one here so um
we were around the 150 ma most of the
time so at 5 29 2 I entered uh so that's
around here okay uh I again I don't know
if I entered here and I was later they
must have been around this Zone here
that's when I entered and you can see
the price went towards the week okay so
that was a very good trip anyway let's
go back to bitcoin that was just to show
you the power of the weeks uh we have a
week to the upside you can see here 28
250 and I work to the downside okay and
the other plan that I was saying
yesterday is uh that so if you want to
go alone you need to see price breaking
above the daily 50 main testing as a
support but if you want to go into
shorts you need to see the opposite okay
you need to see price breaking below the
4 Hour 50ma
test this resistance
that's what I did here and then you're
gonna Target the week okay that's going
to be uh the first Target and where you
should take most of your profits and you
can see that during the decision session
they've hit the wick okay so you know
that's good
um now we are in this moment where we
don't know if price is going to continue
dropping lower or if you can see some
kind of reversal to the website okay so
what I'm gonna try to do here is uh
first let me remove all my my drawings
you know that I don't need them this
week is done
um I'm gonna keep this levels here if we
go yeah within the four hour time frame
okay you can see here
that we are in some kind of range okay
let me show you here
so
you know uh these two blue uh let me
know blue so you can see them better
okay
I would say that we are in this range
between these two blue lines okay uh you
can see that you know that's your high
that's your low will almost came all the
way to the to retest the low that was a
week you know surprise didn't have to
come necessarily all the way here
because you only have to come at least
50 of this week so that was around here
I would say fill the week perfect now
price went again to the top
um it has left a week
so that is telling me that it's likely
the price goes again to those highs here
so uh what I'm thinking is okay we've
swept the highs okay uh remember they're
in a Range if you so the liquidity is
always going to be above the highest and
below the lows okay so we swap the highs
that liquidity is taken we have a quick
surprise at some point it's gonna come
back to to those highs again uh now the
problem is that we haven't solved the
lows yet
okay and by sweeping the lows it doesn't
have to be something like this sorry
something like this okay it could be
even something like this more okay and
that will take you to 25 250 for example
okay uh the thing is that we're having
taken that zone yet so what this is
essentially telling me is that uh if
price continues dumping okay if we lose
this level over here okay if we lose
these two levels over here uh then you
know I'll probably say
now I want to go all the way
to the bottom of the range and the most
likely thing is that then we sweep the
lows and because there is a lot of
liquidity here still because we have a
week and all weeks get failed you just
in the case of polkadot uh then I would
probably say that we're likely to see a
deviation
and then again push to the top of the
range and fill that with okay because
all the weeks get filled
it's as simple as that you can tell me
but there is more liquidity at 22k
and you are right there is a lot of
liquidity check out these two liquidity
pools over here okay so of course there
is liquidity here all the way down but
at the same time
if I have a wick here
I can't this miss the idea that we are
not gonna go again to this highs okay
it's as simple as that now let me have a
look at high block Capital let's see
what is going on uh so far for Bitcoin
you know the first Target is hit that
was the 50 of the week
now let's see what happens also if
you're going to the one hour time frame
all right we're gonna see that maybe the
quickly psychological pattern might be
playing out all right so let me draw
this for you let me try to establish the
weekend range
okay so that's Saturday
around here okay
um then you close on Sunday here okay I
mean you have you can see this year you
can range just start then we can end
this Zone
okay and you finish the weekend in this
song too so you can see that that's a
range of course you have some deviations
okay
that's normal but you can see the price
opened and closed here during that
weekend okay so why not could this be
Monday Force move okay then the weak
strength might be in the opposite
direction okay I don't know how high I
could even go to this level here okay
and then maybe on Thursday
we could see some kind of reversal okay
maybe again to do towards this um
weekend range because remember something
in the vitamin of date we were saying
that we are not expecting
a big move um when I say a big move I
mean around uh two thousand dollars move
because that's I think around uh six
seven percent so for example 27 200.
uh let me try to to see 27 200 if we
drop 2K
that uh seven percent move I'm not
expecting a seven percent move this week
why
because the volatility should really
come in next week
because next week we have CPI
and
the interest rate decision and the Dot
Plot okay so I think that the most
likely thing is that which is something
similar to this this week and you know
um probably we're gonna stick into into
this kind of sum that we've marked you
know uh of course price you know could
always come again to the 50 of this week
why not you know uh but it's likely that
we see some kind of a range in this Zone
okay it's very likely and then next week
with all those news announcements let's
see what they say and try to analyze
them beforehand okay to see what I could
expect but uh next week we could see a
big move or at least a two thousand
dollars that's what I think okay
um that can be to the upside to the
Autumn side
it depends on what they say okay and
that's what we have to try to figure it
out but anyway guys let's go into high
block Capital let's see where the
liquidity is
um the 50 of this week is is filled okay
and the 50 of this one uh it's not
because I think the 50 percent it's
around
this Zone over here and in the four hour
time frame
it's even worse okay because you have a
full Wikia
without being getting filled and Wicks
get filled in all time frames so uh even
if in the one or time frame
the week got filled which isn't because
it's a bit higher okay
filled it doesn't matter because in the
four hour time frame
do you still have a week okay so that's
also what you have to try to to
understand anyway let's go to hybrid
Capital let's see what the liquidity is
I imagine that there is still quality of
liquidity
uh 28 100 that's why I saw the last time
but let's see if we can find something
interesting also to the downside and uh
potential moves okay
well in Pablo Capital let's check those
liquidation levels first
okay the dentist because
um it's pretty much to say that you know
1.8 billion dollars worth of short
liquidations that's nothing okay so
don't pay attention to the Delta now
there is no much going on you can see
like they've been um
changing pretty quickly one billion then
again this peak is another billion
um here it's gonna be 1.7 maybe let me
see if it tells me
1.6 billion here
1.8 billion and now here one dollar is
billion so uh it's not telling me much
to be honest
okay it's not telling me much but you
can see uh that the Liquidations in this
site at the right side of the screen
this spikes are telling you where High
leverage Traders liquidations are okay
so for example uh you can see that there
is a pink Spike here so if you go and
check the left that will be here at 26
400 okay you have
196 million dollars worth of long
liquidations okay and now if you go
below check here those are traders that
using times 25 leverage okay so that's
an interesting story in the chart for
example okay
to the downside well then we know that
26.4 that's quite interesting sum uh I
will I will check now in the chart if
that's the 100 of the week I think yes
okay but then you can see that to the
upside we have some bigger spikes here
too okay you have
um the blue ones are also times 25
Trader so you have
here are 27
470 you have 198 Millions worth of short
liquidations but the biggest part is
here really okay and if you check the
spike that takes you to 27
860. and that's the important level we
have in the chart okay see how it
matches and that's how many liquidations
258 million
dollars okay so I mean I would tell you
that it's quite even
again if you're expecting some kind of a
false move we can't this missed idea of
our last uh maybe stop run towards this
Zone here that would take it to
26.4 okay and then from there we can see
our reversal
to watch this song okay and that would
be towards maybe 27.8
um 27.4 okay so that's what I can see in
this chart that's what it's telling me
that's how I'm interpreting this chart
but if we go to the liquidation levels
let's see what they're telling us okay
sorry to the liquidation hit map
okay uh we're in the seven days time
frame let's zoom in
of course 28 100 that's around the week
to the upside you can see that that's
where there is the most liquidity okay
because you have here
at twenty thousand fifty you have four
and a half billions worth of short
liquidation sorry
then at 28 100 you have five billions
and at 28 150 you have four billion so
that's a total of let's say uh that's
nine and a half
and 13 and a half
thirteen and a half billion dollars
worth of short liquidations between
twenty thousand one hundred or Twenty a
thousand okay so that's a very
interesting Zone in small time travels
you can see here that twenty seven
thousand five hundred you have four and
a half billion dollars worth of short
liquidations okay and again at twenty
six thousand one hundred there are some
liquidity here what's interesting about
this to me it's interesting that if you
notice they are round numbers okay
twenty eight thousand twenty seven
thousand five hundred and twenty six
Cape that's where the liquidity is
usually too okay around the numbers but
if we went to the 12 hours time frame
okay
the seven days time frame is quite clear
that the liquidity is to the website or
lower to 28 100 but if we go into the 12
hours time frame
let's check what's going on here this
chart gets messy sometimes okay so let's
try to
yeah assuming a bit more the biggest
liquidation zones
when you have one very close here guys
uh 26 625 uh we didn't hate it so
um exactly the price comes back to its
own to be honest maybe they are right
the start of the New York session that
could happen
and also 26.4
and even low okay
that's also a week that we have in the
chart 25 850. again I'm not expecting
this week to get filled this week so far
okay I might be wrong with this but uh
I'm expecting that zone to get hit yet
now
if you go to the upside
we have 27k
27.2
and of course 27.8 okay the important
key level that we have in our chart so
uh let's go back to bitcoin I started to
make sense of what we've seen here okay
of course if we go into higher time
frame
I haven't checked the one month for
quite some time let me check this out
because I don't know what I'm gonna find
out here
okay uh again it's not telling me much
really okay uh 22k you can see a lot of
liquidity there also 24 to 5 and of
course around 30k okay uh not much not
much happened in the one month time
frame let's be honest and of course the
three months time frame it's very clear
where the liquidity is here okay
you have 25 400 we've been talking about
this zone for maybe a month
because there was a Zone where we saw
two sell-offs in the chart and it's uh
it was a strong resistance that we
haven't tested our support yet so these
are very important level in the chart
again uh the level if you think about it
would make sense with a sweep of the
lows okay of this range here sweep the
lows hit those liquidations and maybe
you can see some kind of reversal but
you have to be cautious because if
that's not super if the lows and price
keeps dumping then we're gonna Target
another 3K lower okay that's 22 500 soon
okay so that's pretty important so
anyway let's just take the low time
frame let's try to find out what could
happen today and this week so let's try
to go to the chart and make sense of
what we've just seen okay
we're back in the Bitcoin chart let's
try to make some sense of a whips in in
high blood ball what I could say is that
in this one here you have a lot of
liquidity also at 27
800 result of liquidity and at 20
100 but I'm also gonna Mark the fifty
percent of the week okay so the
liquidities to the upside okay that
means that we're gonna try to get into
Longs okay but the question is where
what can we try to get into Longs again
this is a financial advice it's only
made sharing my trading plan uh I
remember that question the liquidation
levels a lot of liquidity at 26 700 okay
and that's around this one I like that
soon because you know you have a quick
here so that would be a sweep of the
lows of that week here so just think
like any Trader that is currently long
now they're gonna Place their stop loss
right before right below this week
okay and this week we also some
liquidity some liquidations okay so if
you put together those liquidations with
the stop losses that's a very
interesting Zone also if you notice in
the chart you have here a liquidity pool
that we marked last week too okay and
it's this one over here
and that liquidity pool goes to
the market for you
twenty six thousand four hundred sixty
nine come on just for one dollar that is
the level do you see what I'm talking
about that's what we call this large
Scandal security pool because when the
market make a smooth price in aggressive
way with these large Candles there is
some Traders okay that opening Longs
okay that opening trades in the same
direction in high level rate so that
means that their liquidations are gonna
be inside this candle okay that's what
we call these liquidity pools and if you
notice
you know we have some Confluence in this
Zone because uh 26 470 you have this
liquid pool you have a sweep of this
week here
and the liquidity of the Horizon the
liquidation level so uh I'm personally
gonna try if we see you know probably
right at the start of the New York
session that's what I would imagine to
say this is to see a stop hunt come to
this low okay sweep the week low fill
the retrace the liquidity pool and then
it's maybe we could see some kind of
reversal okay hopefully this would take
us again to 27k
27.5k maybe 27.8k why not
only until Thursday
and thus we could see some kind of a
midweek reversal back into the weekend
range okay so that's what I'm looking at
for now
um again it's a financial advice it's
only what I'm seeing in the chart but
again 26
470 marketason in your chart
um keep attention to see what happens
okay if you lose this Zone it's not
gonna look great because you're probably
gonna go again to this to this idea here
okay so price go to another 500 right
that's what you have to be cautious
anyway guys I hope that you liked the
video I hope that you found it useful
and I'll see you soon wait before I
finish the video uh regarding the
trading course giveaway I've already
announced the 10 winners I'm gonna go
today through all my DMs in Twitter
because I had a hell of a weekend so I
couldn't go through them so uh today I
send you the invite links for July and I
can already tell you that we are going
to do more giveaways soon so you know if
you've already created an account
immediate posted at least a hundred
dollars and you're trading there but you
haven't won this giveaway don't worry
because you are gonna do more and those
accounts that are going to be already
participating thing for the next
giveaway okay so that also applies to a
new account so if you want to
participate for the next giveaway you
can register using the link in the
description deposit at least a hundred
dollars and trade there and then you're
gonna be participating uh also when you
sign up you get five dollars for free
and deposits between two hundred and a
thousand dollars get 10 payback so if
you for example deposit five hundred
dollars you're gonna get fifty dollars
for free okay if you deposit bigger
amounts uh of course you get bigger
rewards uh but you can check the
information in the link below so now yes
guys thank you so much for watching and
I'll see you soon